how's it going bros my spirit power when
youtubers hit these benchmarks ten
thousand a hundred thousand a million
ten million they usually make some kind
of video myself included saying thank
you for subscribing and showing support
um we didn't really hit a number I mean
we had more numbers than I ever thought
but right now we are right like 31.9 or
something I don't know I just felt like
making a video um just showing my
appreciation instead of just waiting for
us to hit a certain number for it to
happen does that make sense well I think
it is I just wanted to say I just really
appreciate that you bros are enjoying my
videos and taking something out of it um
I feel like as this channel has grown
it's been a constant struggle with
trying to connect with you bros in a
good way it's it's really hard having so
many fans it used to be so much easier
having a smaller fanbase my point is I
appreciate regardless that you bros just
watch my videos that that means the
world to me I put my heart and soul into
this channel some might not believe me
what I say it but I really do and and
that the fact that I can keep doing this
as my job regardless of how many of you
are watching is really what means
something to me and it makes me so happy
to be just be able to do what I do it
makes me so happy I can make a stupid
song about someone sucking ass or one
day just play a random game like I love
what I do and I ate it's just amazing so
make me a little emotional here um and I
feel like you bros who's been there all
the way or maybe yesterday
you were awesome and you make my dreams
come true so before I turn off my
comments I think things were going at
downhill I would say so making that
change it feel like we're going back
we've been going back up and that's been
making me really happy and it's making
me really enjoy what I do
which is something very important to me
I've talked about this before but like I
never want to be a slave to it kind of
for a while I used to only do horror
games and that was it and people used to
get angry at me if I if I covered other
games but I wasn't enjoying doing only
horror games so I had to switch and and
not everyone may like that decision not
everyone might support that decision but
you might support me in the end for for
doing what I want to do and that's that
something very important to me and and I
appreciate you bros even though some
something might not be exactly the way
you want it to be you still support me
that's my point so getting a little
rambling here keep showing your support
I do appreciate it I'm always
appreciated of it I'm never gonna stop
being appreciated of it and I'm never
gonna stop thank you for it anyway
really just thank you for being there
and being a bro it's awesome you're
awesome and I love you so here we go
brofist tab don't bro if it's too hard
alright just lightly touch the screen
that's all you gotta do you ready all
right one two three Brophy